The Swift standard library
has a function called sort,
which is a part of
the sequence type protocol.
This function can be called
by any type that conforms
to the sequence type protocol,
often an array or a dictionary.
The sort function takes one argument,
a closure expression indicating how the
items in a collection should be sorted.
In the end,
the function returns a sorted array.
For example, let's imagine
we're at a silent auction and
we have an array of bids that we'd
like to sort from lowest to highest.
Here's our array of bids
along with an array for
the return value called orderedBids.
The bids array will call
the sort method, and
that's where the closure
expression comes in.
Closure expressions typically take
the form in between curly braces,
first you'll see the parameters being
passed in, followed by an arrow
pointing to the return type, similar to
what you'd see in a function signature.
Then the return type is
followed by the word, in,
and then the statements to be executed.
Back up here in the closure we're
passing into the sort function,
notice that there's no name.
We skip straight to the curly braces.
In between curly braces, first we
write the parameters being passed in,
which are Ints.
We're passing in two Ints
from the array each time.
Sort always takes two parameters that
match the type of the array calling
the function.
After the parameters we see an arrow
pointing to the return type.
The return type here is a bool
indicating whether bid1 should be placed
before bid2 or not.
Next comes the word, in, signaling the
beginning of the executable statements.
And then the executable statement
in this case is very short.
It's just bid2 > bid1.
If bid2 is greater than bid1, then bid1
should go first in the sorted array.
If we print out the results,
the orderedBids array,
we can see that the bids are in
order from lowest to highest.
Let's alter the example just a bit and
say that the auction goers
put in more exact bids.
They put in their bids in as doubles.
How would our closure expression change?
In this case,
since the parameters are now doubles,
we'll need to change the parameter
types of bid1 and bid2.
But notice that the return type and the
sorting statement both remain the same.
Let's do one more example for
good measure.
Let's say we're sorting
an array of birthYears and
we want to put the years in
reverse chronological order.
What should our closure
expression look like?
What should we place
between curly braces here?
Like before, we're sorting an array
of Ints, which means that the two
parameters passed into the closure
expression will also be Ints.
Let's call those parameters year1 and
year2.
Next comes an arrow pointing
to the return type.
And remember that sort always takes
a closure with the same return type, and
that return type is a bool.
Next comes the word,
in, to signal the beginning of
the closure's executable statements.
And since we want the birth years in or
verse chronological order that means
the bool should return true if
year1 is greater than year2.
And over here in the sidebar,
we can see our sorted array.
Even though in this case the array is
sorted essentially instantaneously,
you can see that the closure represents
a passing of the flow of control.
It's as if we're saying, here,
sort, take this chunk of code and
use it when you need it.